[Musique]
bienvenue en débat sur france 24 43e
jour de guerre en ukraine depuis la
découverte des exactions de butch à
l'évocation des crimes de l'armée russe
a pris une nouvelle dimension volodymyr
zellers qui évoque un génocide kef
utilisait déjà ce terme pour dénoncer le
siège de marioupol l'espagne et la
pologne l'ont repris washington paris et
berlin préfère parler de crimes de
guerre l'onu a lancé une enquête
indépendante la cour pénale
internationale a ouvert une
investigation et la procureur général
d'ukraine documente les exactions
commises depuis le début de la guerre la
russie ni jean yves le drian a même
convoqué l'ambassadeur de russie en
france après la publication d'un tweet
assimilant butch à un plateau de
tournage une réponse à l'indécence et à
la provocation de la communication russe
a tweeté le chef de la diplomatie
française abuja à marioupol de quoi
parle-t-on peut-on évoquer un génocide
en ukraine l'armée russe peut-elle être
condamné pour crime de guerre ou crimes
contre l'humanité poutine devra-t-il
rendre des comptes on en débat avec mes
invités j'ai plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
cécile coudriou bonsoir à vous sa
présidente d'amnesty international
france bienvenue dans le débat en face
de vous vous nous avons emmanuel daoud
de bonsoir avocat au barreau de paris
spécialiste en droit pénal international
et inscrit également sur la liste des
avocats auprès de la cour pénale
internationale bienvenue à vous
également nicolas tenzer est avec nous
bonsoir enseignant à sciences po
directeur de la publication 'dès que
russie à bienvenus et puis en face de
vous le général dominique trinquant
bonsoir ancien chef de la mission
militaire française auprès de l'onu nous
avons également à kiev notre
correspondant stéphane sirot ans
stéphane bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
pendant ce débat avant de démarrer la
discussion je vous propose de faire un
point en images avec nos confrères de
france 3
dans le cimetière de boudhha c'est un
décompte macabre qui paraît sans fin
au milieu de dizaines de sacs mortuaires
des ukrainiens répertorie les hommes et
les femmes morts au cours de
l'occupation russe
avant de les évacuer dans ses camions
à entendre ces volontaires de nombreuses
victimes auraient été exécutés
il ya beaucoup de corps en un jour et on
en a collecté 30 ils sont sur le sol là
certains ont reçu des balles dans la
tête bien que d'autres ont été tués
alors qu'ils avaient les yeux bandés et
les mains liées
plus d'une semaine après le départ des
troupes russes un collectif d'activistes
ukrainien appeler une forme napalm
assure avoir trouvé l'homme responsable
du massacre de boudhha
voici le lieutenant-colonel azad bec aux
murs baeckeoffe l'officier à la tête de
la brigade russe qui a occupé la ville
sur cet autre cliché on le voit peu
avant son départ pour l'ukraine fin 2021
se faire photographier aux côtés d'un
prêtre orthodoxe
si son implication est avérée cet
officier russe n'est sans doute pas le
seul responsable des exactions commises
en ukraine près de kherson à l'autre
bout du pays cette femme raconte avoir
été violée par des soldats russes parce
qu'elle est l'épousé d'un militaire
ukrainien
ils sont entrés par la porte derrière
moi je n'ai pas eu le temps de prendre
mon téléphone ni de faire quoi que ce
soit ils m'ont juste poussée sur le lit
ont écrasés avec la mitrailleuse ils
m'ont déshabillé
chaque jour des dizaines de témoignages
comme celui ci sont collectées par les
autorités ukrainiennes
de son côté la russie assure que son
armée ne s'est rendue coupable d' aucune
exaction dans le pays
on va écouter tout de suite le patron de
l'otan je vienne stoltenberg
c'était cet après-midi
les alliés condamne fermement les
horribles meurtres de civils que nous
avons vu abuja et dans d'autres endroits
récemment libéré de contrôle russe
tous les fai doivent être établies tous
les responsables de ces atrocités
doivent être traduits en justice et les
alliés soutiennent les efforts déployés
pour mener une enquête internationale
machin vaste gâchis
maintenant les 10 meilleurs et lens qui
le président ukrainien qui s'est exprimé
après s'être rendu à bout de chasse
étaient lundi
nous pensons que ce sont des crimes de
guerre et que tout cela sera reconnu par
le monde comme un génocide
vous êtes ici aujourd'hui et vous pouvez
voir de vos propres yeux ce qu'il s'est
passé nous savons qu'il y ait des
milliers de personnes tuées torturées
avec des membres coupés défi violé des
enfants assassinés
stéphane dion à kiev je voulais d'abord
voir avec vous comment réagit-on en
ukraine quand hélas qui évoque un
génocide en ukraine je sais que la
procureure générale en ukraine à kiev a
ouvert une enquête
qu'est ce qu'on en dit là-bas
alors génocide c'est le mot qui revient
prioritairement dans la parole des gens
que ce soit les commentateurs les
journalistes les hommes politiques mais
également la population vous savez en
ukraine il manque encore un tout petit
peu de culture sur ces concepts
juridiques que sont les crimes de guerre
les crimes contre l'humanité le génocide
le mot génocide est un mot qui a été
utilisé à tort et à travers ces huit
dernières années aussi bien par la
partie russe que par la partie
ukrainienne
on pourra définir ce qui se passait dans
le donbass on se souvient que la russie
utilisé cette question du génocide des
populations russophones dont base
quelque chose qui n'avait absolument pas
de sens mais du côté ukrainien on
utilisait également le mot génocide pour
des réalités qui n'en étaient pas
néanmoins le mot génocide évoque
beaucoup de choses pour les ukrainiens
et c'est pas un hasard s'il est utilisé
par le président volodymyr zelensky et
par les ukrainiens parce que les
ukrainiens ont une conscience profonde
en tant que peuple d'avoir subi un
génocide dans les années 1930
l'holodomor les famines provoquer
artificiellement par staline qui ont
provoqué entre 4 et 7 millions de morts
mais également l'élimination de la
classe intellectuelle lors des purges
staliniennes au début des années 30 où
on estime que 75 à 80% des professions
intellectuelles ukrainienne notamment
les écrivains et les journalistes ont
été éliminés avec un mode opératoire des
balles dans la nuque et les mains liées
qui rappelle énormément ce ce qu'on voit
à bout de chat donc il ya un passif
historique dans la relation entre
l'ukraine et la russie qui fait que les
ukrainiens n'hésite absolument pas a
qualifié ces événements de génocide même
s'il enquête n'a pas encore eu lieu et
qu'il faudra encore que les enquêteurs
établissent les faits et la
qualification juridique mail daoud vous
êtes l'avocat justement de ce plateau
votre réaction vous pourrez on pourrait
parler de génocide ou est ce que le
terme utilisé par les élèves qui est il
utilisé à tort écoutez on peut
comprendre du côté des ukrainiens des
ukrainiennes que ce terme soit employé
est ce qu'ils répondent à la définition
juridique et celle de la cour pénale
internationale il est trop tôt pour le
dire les jeunes aussi qui ont été
reconnus sont les génocides de juifs
arméniens et tutsi se trouvent donc ça
fait oui c'est tout vrai s'agissant du
massacre de srebrenica le tribunal
spécial a reconnu des meurtres à
caractère génocidaire on en est là il
faut beau qu'il y ait un crime de
génocide
la volonté d'éradiquer d'éliminer un
peuple une nation en raison de son
origine raciale ethnique ou
confessionnelle
je ne sais pas si à l'issue de cette
guerre dont nous souhaitons tous et
toutes qu'elle se termine au plus haut
point le plus rapidement possible cette
agression commise par la russie il faut
à faire le décompte c'est comme ça que
ça se passe et le décompte des massacres
le démon monde le décompte des
exécutions civile et savoir s'il ya eu
un plan délibéré au niveau du kremlin et
au niveau de vladimir poutine pour
éliminer la nation ukrainienne c'est cet
élément-là plan délibéré qu'il fait à
distance
systématique entre génocide crimes
contre l'humanité et crimes de guerre
exactement on regarde le pour le moment
je ne crois pas même si on comprend
l'émotion des ukrainiennes ou des crimes
qu'ils qui sommes nous pour mettre en
doute on creuse légitimité de leurs
émotions qu'on puisse employer ce terme
juridique comme cela on va regarder
d'ailleurs parce qu'on a fait on un peu
répertorier la différence entre génocide
qui en fait tout acte commis dans
l'intention de détruire vous le disais
en tout ou partie un groupe national
ethnique racial ou religieux qui est
donc différent du crime contre
l'humanité tout acte commis dans le
cadre d'une attaque généralisée ou
systématique lancée contre toute
population civile et en connaissance de
cette attaque et enfin le crime de
guerre parce que tout est défini il faut
le voir en droit interne nal crimes de
guerre tout acte s'inscrivant dans le
cadre d'un plan ou d'une politique
lorsqu ils font partie d'une série de
crimes analogues commis sur une grande
échelle on peut dire finalement que le
crime de guerre cécile coudriou et le
plus le plus vague lille pourrait en
fait on pourrait déjà parlé pratiquement
de crimes de guerre ce n'est pas vague
mais c'est important justement en tout
cas pour un mouvement comme destination
qui est fondée sur le droit
international des droits humains et qui
veille aussi au respect du droit
international humanitaire forcément que
les mots vont avoir un sens très précis
il faudrait pas croire que les crimes de
guerre ce n'est pas grave c'est que
c'est parce que je pensais plus vague
c'est à dire mais je dois partir on a
forcément l'intention derrière disons
que c'est plus simple parfois ya une
surenchère dans les termes parce que les
personnes ont l'impression que ça sera
plus pris au sérieux si on dit génocide
mais les crimes de guerre je tiens à le
dire c'est effectivement extrêmement
grave ça veut dire d'une part qu'on fait
aucune distinction entre les civils et
les militaires cela veut dire aussi
qu'on s'en prend à des soldats qui ont
été faits prisonniers notamment avec la
torture ou également des humiliations et
donc dans le cas effectivement de
l'ukraine toutes les enquêtes que nous
sommes en train de mener avec nos
propres chercheurs sur le terrain ou à
distance nous avons effectivement pu
relever des éléments de preuve qu'il
s'agit bien de violations flagrantes
d'une part parce qu'il y à une
utilisation d'armes massive qui sont sur
des zones civiles ce qui est totalement
proscrit par le droit international ce
sont parfois des armes qui sont
interdites parce qu'elles sont justement
par nature un discriminante comme ces
bombes à sous munitions ou qu'on appelle
aussi bombes à fragmentation et qui donc
font des ravages parmi les civils donc
il y à des crimes de guerre je dirais
par frappes aériennes mais il ya eu
aussi une enquête beaucoup plus récentes
de la part de nos chercheurs qui a
démontré qu effectivement ce qui s'est
passé à la butch à mais aussi dans
d'autres villes autour de kiev relèvent
de crimes relèvent vrai jeu manquant de
conditions parce que pour être prudente
des crimes de guerre dans la mesure où
des soldats s'en serait pris à des
civils y compris avec tortures viols
exécutions sommaires qu'on appelle aussi
exécutions extrajudiciaires tout cela
est extrêmement grave et ça deviendrait
importance de l'enquète et ça deviendra
un crime contre l'humanité si on pouvait
prouver c'était vraiment à caractère
systématique c'est dire qu'à une
planification systématique même si c'est
pas encore l'éradication de toute partie
qui était encore un cran au dessus donc
il a effectivement une graduation mais
je voudrais surtout pas qu'on banalise
les crimes de guerre parce que c'est en
tout cas pour l'avenir poutine justement
devenue une tactique classique qu'il
faut à tout prix mettre en lumière et
montrer à quel point ça n'est pas
acceptable qu'il faut que justice puisse
être faite nicolas tenzer on a vu dans
le sujet avec lequel on a démarré ce
débat que des bourreaux russe à bout de
chats auraient été identifiés par des
ukrainiens en l'occurrence à l'aide de
des réseaux sociaux ukrainien c'est le
lieutenant-colonel azad pf au mourre
baeckeoffe pardon un soldat russe en
fait de 20 ans qui en fait aurait été
identifié ça ajoute à lenquête est ce
que finalement de la technosphère
ukrainienne est précieuse pour assembler
de tels éléments oui d'abord c'est
extrêmement précieux jeu quand même
revenir sur un des éléments parce que
cécile l'a très bien dit tout à l'heure
à d'abord il n'ya pas de hiérarchie
entre ces trois catégories de crimes
crimes de guerre contre l'humanité et
crimes de génocide tous les trois sont
des crimes imprescriptibles ça c'est
quand même la première chose
deuxièmement il y a quand même un
facteur qui est très important vous
parler de ce colonel c'est que les
responsabilités ce sont des
responsabilités à la fois qui concerne
les donneurs d'ordre et la de ce point
de vue là il ya un donneur d'ordre qui
est un criminel de guerre depuis 22 ans
comme le rappelait qu'il admire poutine
l'ensemble de son armée et les
exécutants et je crois que c'est bien
l'ensemble de cette personne il s'agit
de visées dans une enquête
internationale quant à monsieur vladimir
poutine on sait très bien je disais
depuis 22 ans ce que l'on voit
aujourd'hui en ukraine c'est déjà ce que
nous avons vu à grossemy c'est ce qu'on
a vu en géorgie en 2008 ça a été jugé
par la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme en 2008 et à une échelle encore
plus vaste et délibérée en syrie et je
me rappelle très bien qu'on nous disions
cela à propos de la syrie en 2016
quand on montrait qu'il s'agissait d'
une guerre d'extermination et que les
crimes étaient non seulement évidemment
encore plus vaste de bachar el assad
mais également de vladimir poutine qui a
quand même tué en syrie plus de civils
syriens que même des gens disent oui
mais c'est pas grave et à part ça on
après ça on a serré la main de monsieur
poutine est ce que nous reste serré la
main quand même on peut se poser la
question d'un sommet de la dden ou
d'abou bakr al bagdadi quelle est la
différence sinon que l'un porte une
cravate est une puissance nucléaire
et que l'autre le dernier anna quand
même comme plus en terme de crimes que
les deux premiers c'est ça la différence
et je crois que c'est ça qu'il faut dire
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
une surprise c'est la continuation
exactement de la même chose qui est déjà
arrivé général de 8,57 rebondir sur ce
que vient de dire nicolas tenzer et puis
également sur ce fameux colonel qui a
été identifié comme justement étant à
l'origine d'un certain nombre
d'atrocités à abuja oui alors je pense
que danser ses crimes de guerre qui ont
été commis il faut voir un peu
l'environnement au départ on alors on
accuse ce que le nail pour ses crimes de
cette région là mais le problème est
est-ce que c'est dans tous les villages
qui ont été occupée par des troupes
russes que c'est répéter la même chose
donc lui est un parmi les responsables
hiérarchiques dans l'armée russe qui a
commis ces crimes là et ça veut dire que
là parce que bout de chat a été
identifiée parce qu'on a des éléments ou
connais très bien la brigade qui était
dans fin je dire elle a été identifiée
et donc chef est toujours responsable de
ce qui se passe sous ses ordres donc lui
a été identifié mais ça c'est le
nord-ouest de kiev mais au nord-est de
kiev on est en train de découvrir
d'autres villes donc dans lesquelles il
est arrivé la même chose est-ce que
l'armée russe a une réputation de
commettre des exactions oui alors
l'armée russe globalement à une pratique
de la violence
alors vous me direz la guerre c'est la
violence mais violence contre ses
propres soldats violence contre ses
propres soldats les conscrits qui sont
inscrits qui arrivent dans leur régiment
sont maltraités tout le monde le sait ça
c'est le premier point donc la violence
fait partie de cet environnement ensuite
vous le site y est à propos de monsieur
poutine globalement l'ambiance en russie
celle usage de la force et la violence
c'est il ya qu'à voir les émissions
télévision russe les shows télévisés
c'est absolument incroyable ça c'est les
deux facteurs globaux et puis il ya
ponctuellement les facteurs qui ont été
appliqués là c'est à dire on l'a bien vu
par les témoignages qui était donné des
soldats qui étaient saouls qui s'amusait
à tirer sur les gens
et c'est donc là il ya clairement des
problèmes de hiérarchie mais l'armée
russe a un problème majeur pour ce sujet
là c'est qu'elle a très peu
d'encadrement elle a désormais fier vous
citiez ce lieutenant colonel qui
commande une brigade chez nous c'est au
moins un général est en dessous vous
descendez vous avez un sous-officier
pour dix hommes dans l'armée russe il ya
quasiment pas de sous-officiers donc ça
veut dire qu'il n'ya pas d'encadrement
pour les hommes ça veut dire que
l'encadrement je rappelle c'est quand
même celui qui est fait est chargé faire
respecter la discipline donc ont-ils
donnait les ordres de faire ça où
ont-ils laissé faire peu importe le
problème elle même à la cave enel benz
qui suit rajouter un petit mot c'est
aussi une permissivité c'est à dire que
le crime est permis c'est limpide masque
il n'est pas là et parce qu'il est
impuni le jeu mais il est impuni aussi
dans la société russe quand on voit
effectivement les assassinats politiques
qui ont eu lieu contre des journalistes
les défenseurs de droits de l'homme etc
c'est aussi cette réalité là emmanuel
daoud comment passe-t-on justement de la
responsabilité d'un colonel de l'armée
russe a la responsabilité de vladimir
poutine ce sera une enquête de terrain
on part de la base du terrain on
identifie les brigades les régiments on
voit ce qui s'est passé les médecins
légistes vont opérer sur chacun sur
chacun des corps est ce qu'il ya eu des
exécutions avec quelle balle les
fragments d'os bus seront recueillies et
l'on verra qu'elle a été s'il ya eu ou
non en faisant cette cartographie des
exactions s'il ya eu un plan délibéré et
ensuite on remontera comment nos comme
un entonnoir vers la hiérarchie et
lorsque vladimir poutine se met en scène
on l'a tous vu cette scène avec ses
généraux à l'autre bout de la table et
qu'il est le chef des armées mais qu'il
le fait bien sentir et qu'il y à tout ce
discours de propagande qu'il assume je
crois que la responsabilité
y est rare chic politique éthique moral
et je le crois juridique remontera
jusqu'à lui et je suis mais vous pouvez
pas savoir combien je suis heureux de
vous avoir entendu parce que sur le fait
que pour les avocats et les avocates de
droit pénal international les militants
des droits humains vladimir poutine est
un criminel de guerre multirécidiviste
et il vit dans l'impunité et je le dis
mais sans esprit de polémique
on l'a reçu à versailles et on l'a reçu
au fort de brégançon et donc il faut
aussi en tirer des conséquences c'est
hommes se croient tout permis c'est fini
la justice pénale internationale va
passer alors justement va écouter à ce
qu'en disent les russes puisque
évidemment la russie ennemie ni elle
parle d'une manipulation ukrainienne les
russes parlent d'ailleurs de mise en
scène littéralement de scènes de
cadavres on va écouter l'ambassadeur
russe à l'onu et view look caire pour
lui si vous regardez attentivement une
bouche ce qu'il y à abuja les cadavres
gisant dans la rue deux streets il
n'était pas là avant que les troupes
russes arrivent
pardon avant qu'elle parte
soudainement ils apparaissent dans la
rue
on va regarder également je vous ferai
j'ai regardé avant de réagir le tweet
qui date d'aujourd'hui de l'ambassadeur
de russie en france qui montre cette
image truquée de boudhha en parlant de
plateaux de tournage c'est à dire qu'ils
assimilent butch à un plateau de
tournage réaction quasi immédiate de
jean yves le drian le chef de la
diplomatie française qui a répondu en
convoquant l'ambassadeur de russie en
france puisque jean yves le drian a
parlé d'indécence et de provocation de
la communication russe je vous fait
réagir mais juste avant stéphane dion à
kiev que dit-on justement de ces de
cette propagande russe
vous savez les ukrainiens ne regarde pas
la télévision russe tout simplement
parce que les médias russes ne sont pas
autorisés en ukraine ou alors il faut
les regarder avec des vpn mais
généralement sur internet les ukrainiens
savent très bien qu est ce qui se dit à
la télé russe moi je vais vous donner un
exemple un qui montrent qu'il ya quand
même des signaux avant coureurs sur
l'intention de violence extrême de la
part de la russie il y a quelques mois
il ya vu des déclarations à la
télévision russe de piotr tolstoï qui
est le vice président de la douma qui
représente également la russie à
l'assemblée parlementaire du conseil de
l'europe et qui avait déclaré à la
télévision russe que les ukrainiens
faisait partie du peuple russe et que
pour régler cette question il fallait
exécuter les dirigeants ukrainiens et
les pendre à des lampadaires à kiev donc
en fait c'est le langage et qui est
utilisé par le kremlin et c'est des
choses qu'on entend en ukraine il n'y a
pas véritablement de surprise sur le
langage alors on va dire génocide bien
c'était le mot encore est un peu fort
mais sur la violence extrême qui est
utilisé par les dirigeants russes
lorsqu'il parle de de l'ukraine donc ça
c'est une des choses que je voulais dire
et l'autre chose pour laquelle il n'y a
pas de raison pour laquelle il n'y a pas
de surprise c'est qu'il ya des signaux
avant coureurs depuis 2004 14 ce à quoi
on est en train d'assister n'est pas
quelque chose de nouveau la guerre dont
le dombass à commencer en 2014 et des
enlèvements des exécutions
extrajudiciaires des viols des actes
considérés comme des crimes de guerre il
y en a eu depuis 2014 et je donnerai
quelques exemples le comité helsinki a
commencé à étudier depuis 2014 sur des
actes qui ont été commis à ce la viande
et akram à tort ce que notamment des
rapts et des viols un autre exemple
c'est que la fondation denis mukwege
guide du nom du de ce gynécologue
congolais bien connu et le et commence à
travailler en ukraine il ya environ
trois ans elle mène des programmes sur
la réhabilitation de femmes qui ont
connu des violences sexuelles et puis il
ya plein de cas qui ont été documentés
je rappellerai également le livre écrit
par ce journaliste ukrainien stanislav
acf organise originaire de donetsk et
qui a été en prison ado n'y est que dans
ce qu'il appelle un camp de
concentration le camp isolé attia et
donc il y a déjà des actes qui ont été
bien étudié et d'ailleurs la cour pénale
internationale le vice procureur de la
cour pénale internationale a lancé une
enquête il y a environ deux ans si je ne
m'abuse sur des faits de crimes de
guerre et de crimes contre l'humanité en
ukraine ont ce qui se passe n'est
absolument rien de nouveau il n'est pas
une surprise pour les ukrainiens alors
rien de nouveau dit stéphane cioran et
je voudrais vous faire réagir ses si le
côté rien de nouveau mais effectivement
on peut dire qu'avec gooch ta wicha il
ya une sorte de palier qui est un peu
franchi dans ce conflit en tout cas sur
la réaction internationale sur l'émotion
qu'elle a pu provoquer est-ce que c'est
plus compliqué aujourd'hui parce que
vous avez ce discours en face de vous ce
discours de propagande russe est-ce que
c'est plus compliqué justement de mettre
en place une enquête de retrouver les
différents les différentes preuves est
ce que les russes s'organisent pour
justement fallait faire disparaître par
exemple avez tout à fait raison l'une
des priorités outre la collecte de
preuves c'est la préservation ses
preuves parce qu'on sait que bien
souvent les personnes qui commettent de
tels crimes ont vraiment pour aussi
obsession ne surtout pas laisser de
trace donc ça c'est effectivement
extrêmement important il ya également
cette question de la propagande
constante également de la profusion
d'image donc paradoxalement ça peut
devenir en effet plus compliqué dans ce
qu'il y à un tel flot d'imagés un tel
flot de propagande il faut bien le dire
quand même que c'est parfois aussi du
côté des hurricanes il ya ni des
réalisations ont calé le plan des laïcs
ont pris à l'époque de la guerre du
donbass il ya eu effectivement aussi des
exactions commises il faut quand même
avoir l'honnêteté de le dire même si
aujourd'hui on a tous évidemment avant
tout des émotions très fortes par
rapport à ce que subissent les
populations civiles ukrainienne donc il
faut aimer ce que je veux dire c'est le
vrai du faux là donc c'est pourquoi il
est tellement important évidemment je
vais avoir de prêcher pour ma paroisse
mais des mouvements comme amnesty
international ont justement cette
vocation à être indépendant impartial
dans la recherche que nous menons avec
les chercheurs sur le terrain mais aussi
à distance notre obsession constante
c'est être sûr qu'il n'y a justement pas
eu de falsification et dont nous allons
vérifier avec nos moyens numériques que
les photos les vidéos ils n'ont
absolument pas pu être falsifiés dans
les comparer les images satellite pour
être sûr c'est bien à tel endroit parce
qu'il ya des preuves comme tel arbre ou
telle météo que c'est bien ce jour là et
pas un autre jour pour pouvoir ensuite
répondre à ce mur de mensonge cette
marée de mensonges même et ses examens
des perceuses qui sont sur le terrain
aujourd'hui nous allons effectivement
dalle il ya eu déjà plusieurs missions
sur le terrain notamment une très
récemment non seulement à butch hamedan
je leur ai peut-être plusieurs villages
autour et dont nous avons eu
effectivement nous aussi des témoignages
absolument effarant de personnes qui ont
été des femmes qui ont été violées après
que leurs maris et ex est exécuté de
manière sommaire il ya eu effectivement
des témoignages montrant que des snipers
tiré volontairement sur des civils
lorsqu'il cherchait à s'enfuir nous
avons de plus en plus de preuves mais ce
qui est beaucoup plus compliqué c'est
d'établir après la chaîne de
commandement la chaîne de
responsabilités et c'est pourquoi on
peut comprendre cet emballement
médiatique c'est aujourd'hui
effectivement avec les réseaux sociaux
tout se passe en temps réel pour la
première fois on enquête pendant que la
guerre se produit c'est une soirée par
rapport au rwanda par amy 20 ans ou plus
par rapport à la bien sûr l'ex
yougoslavie il y avait des exactions
commises qui était sans doute du même
degré d'horreur on va pas comparer les
horreurs c'est pas ça le but le but
c'est de se dire qu'il faut appeler à la
prudence d'autant plus parce que tout
cela nous sidère au sens propre du terme
et c'est pourquoi vous faites est un
mélange entre l'émotion la lfb mais si
on veut répondre au titre de votre sujet
aujourd'hui si on veut vraiment que
poutine réponde de ses actes également
les généraux les commandes ans à tous et
même des ministres d'ailleurs qu'on mise
des armées puissent répondre de leurs
actes il faut être particulièrement
minutieux prendre le temps de l'enquète
et même des enquêtes parce qu'elles ont
lu en parallèle en ce moment il ya celle
des ong il ya c'est effectivement de
l'ukraine il ya celle des enquêteurs de
l'onu il ya une coordination entre
toutes ces différentes anglais en tout
cas une nous avons vocation à aider à la
justice que ce soit celle de la cour
pénale internationale qu'elle mène une
enquête aussi en ce moment si on peut
aider également dans d'autres domaines y
compris la justice ukrainienne elle-même
il faut qu'il y ait en parallèle
plusieurs travaux menés mais à chaque
fois il faut croiser les informations et
être certain qu'on pourra vraiment
établir lancement des films et des
responsabilités parce qu'on a tous soif
de justice et que cette lutte contre
l'impunité obtiennent enfin des
victoires par rapport à vladimir poutine
ce que je partage complètement ce qui
est dit sur ce plateau ça fait trop
longtemps que ça dure avec la syrie on
se rappelle ses propos sur les
tchétchènes qu'il allait chercher jusque
dans les toilettes pour est plus poli
que lui les terroristes selon lui don
diaboliser l'ennemi pour pouvoir après
finalement tenté de justifier
l'injustifiable c'est dans l'inhumanité
c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment
très coutumier chez la dîmière poutine
nicolas kaiser
je rajoute un point sur ce qu'a dit
stéphane sirot qui est vraiment très
important c'est que ces crimes existe
depuis longtemps il ya un autre
rendez vous allemand gardant mais non
mais ça se donner un exemple un exemple
précis sur eux un autre exemple c'est la
crimée la crim est occupée ou là vous
avez est aussi documenté des
disparitions forcées d'un certain nombre
de tares et ça c'est quelque chose aussi
qui était un crime passé et ça veut dire
aussi pour le futur peut être un élément
sur le futur si vous permettez c'est que
peut-être que dans la masse des crimes
commis actuellement en ukraine
probablement que les pires crimes ont
été commis à marioupol il continue à
marioupol et les russes tentent
actuellement semble-t-il de faire
disparaître toutes les traces c'est à
dire concrètement les cadavres à mario
paul et ça veut dire aussi que si nous
n'agissons pas immédiatement
nous européens nous alliés de l'otan on
va avoir ses crimes qu'ils vont se
répéter ces crimes ils sont prévisibles
ils sont prêts dit demain il y en aura
d'autres et c'est l'urgence de l'action
aujourd'hui qui commandent des vitesses
écrémé sap politiquement ne pouvons pas
savoir il ya cette responsabilité la
responsabilité de protéger la
responsabilité d'éviter elle pèse
aujourd'hui général devant l'histoire
est donné sur des pôles de nos
dirigeants général dominique train quand
est ce qu effectivement il ya quelque
chose de très particulier dans cette
guerre à la fois donc ce don sicile
coudriou parlait c'est à dire cette
immédiateté on a cette information
quasiment en direct donc attention à la
propagande des deux côtés est ce que
c'est un peu inédit ça oui alors moi
d'abord je voudrais saluer le travail
qui est fait parce qu'effectivement la
documentation de tout ça est absolument
essentiel quand on se retrouvera la cpi
ceux qui ont protégé se trouve attaqué
il faut bien voir ça donc c'est assez
compliqué donc je salue vraiment ça par
ailleurs
effectivement attention à l'emballement
médiatique sur un certain nombre
d'éléments
moi je veux bien qu'on dise qu'il
fallait intervenir ça veut dire quoi
intervenir aujourd'hui on parle on ne
pouvait pas parler à poutine très bien
moi j'étais en yougoslavie j'ai parlé à
milosevic karadzic et mladic qui sont
des criminels de guerre mais comment est
ce qu'on fait quand on veut obtenir une
trêve quelque part et quand on veut
arriver à sauver des personnes on dit
souvent que quand on veut dîner avec le
diable il faut le faire avec une grande
cuillère 20 pardonnez-moi mais ceux qui
sont en responsabilité et non pas sur un
plateau où on est un peu au calme quand
même pour faire les choses
c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça et
donc
je salue tout le travail il faut
absolument documenté tout ça il faut
avancer sur tous ces domaines là mais ne
pas se faire sans balai sur un certain
nombre de choses et vous avez raison de
deux répété qu' il ya des crimes dans la
guerre il ya des crimes et il faut
documenter pour savoir si ces dessins
incidents qui sont venus il y avait eu
des affaires au vietnam où c'était un
chef de section qui avaient commis des
crimes oissel chef de section qui a
commis un crime ou bien si ça remonte
jusqu'à poutine et il faut documenter
tout ça pour arriver à en tirer des
conclusions et puis il ya aussi des
précédents malheureusement de personnes
qui ont été acquittés je pense à jean
pierre bemba notamment qu'il ait
quelqu'un accusé de choses terribles
comme le viol comme arme de guerre qui
malheureusement devient un grand
classique dans le cadre de guerre est
donc ici un complément vainement de
nombreux pays et nombreux si les souabes
béton dès que le dossier à des petites
faiblesses ça peut immédiatement lettre
la fin finalement de l'accès à la
justice est pourquoi emmanuel da ou
parce que moi on me rappelle à chaque
fois que en irak il ya eu des crimes et
que tony blair n'est jamais passé devant
là surgit et giorgio baldi bouche non
plus lorsqu'on regarde j'ai regardé
milosevic moi je pensais qu'il avait été
condamné mais même n'ont pas vraiment il
a été inculpé de crimes de guerre de
crimes contre l'humanité mais finalement
il est mort en détention donc il n'y a
pas eu de condamnation
bachar el-assad alors quid de bachar
el-assad j'ai vu qu'il y avait un
ensemble de procédures maintenant une
procédure en allemagne bref bachar al
assad accusé de crimes de guerre de
crimes contre l'humanité par l'onu et
d'ailleurs est toujours en poste
toujours à son poste en syrie donc c'est
difficile de se dire qu'on peut arriver
jusqu'à vladimir poutine et finalement
de l'annuaire poutine serait-il le seul
acquis qu'ils devraient rendre des
comptes non il faut rester impartial
hors
jeu
je voudrais simplement réagir un propos
de votre propos monsieur
oui c'est plus simple d'être sur un tas
être sur un plateau et de délivrer des
paroles définitives je considère pour ma
part et je le redis que les dirigeants
occidentaux une responsabilité politique
morale et éthique d'avoir accepté de ne
pas traiter vladimir poutine pour ce
qu'il est un criminel de guerre qui a
agi depuis 1999 et il faut le dire il
faut le redire me semble-t-il je vais
répondre à votre question
la justice pénale internationale
elle se développe sur plusieurs niveaux
il y à une enquête devant la cour pénale
internationale
il y a la procureure par la justice
ukrainienne qui est saisie il y à des
états qui sur le fond d'enceintes home
technique de la compétence universelle
ouvrent des enquêtes et donc ce qu'il
faut retenir c'est que la cour pénale
internationale est la seule juridiction
qui peut juger des chefs d'état en
exercice il y a pas d'impunité possible
les autres juridictions pourrait juger
un vladimir poutine entre guillemets à
la retraite et qui ne seraient plus chef
d'état est ce que les russes le
livrerons est ce que on n'en sait rien a
priori non slobodan milosevic
il était tout puissant en serbie
jusqu'au jour où il a perdu les
élections et que la communauté
internationale a dit aux serbes si vous
voulez réintégrer le banc des nations si
vous voulez qu'on vous aide il va
falloir que nous vous nous le livre y
est c'est la police serbe qui
l'interpellé et c'est la police serbe
qui l'a remis à la cour pénale
internationale
donc moi je suis je suis avocat je suis
optimiste et je pense qu'il faut aller
de l'avant et il faut pas être
défaitiste par rapport à cela a
évidemment général vous avez raison il
faut être prudent évidemment qu'il faut
documenter et ce travail de
documentation de collecte il faut le
faire de la façon la plus rigoureuse
parce que aussi surprenant que cela
puisse paraître le jour voyez chevaux ou
vladimir poutine sera devant une
juridiction il bénéficiera de la
présomption d'innocence id aura le droit
de se défendre et il aura certainement
des avocats et des avocates très
compétent pour le défendre mais si le
travail de documentation de collecte des
preuves est fait de façon
professionnelle
et vous avez raison de le souligner on
est c'est la première fois que ça se
passe dans l'histoire une documentation
une collecte des preuves en temps réel
il y en a peut-être trop mais on va y
arriver et je pense que lui comme bachar
el-assad et d'autres répondront de leurs
actes stéphane durand qu'est ce qu'on en
dit en ukraine puisque la procureure de
d'ukraine est très active me semble-t-il
à kiev
oui tout à fait il ya deux jours la
procureure du général d'ukraine irina
benedicto va a déclaré que le parquet
lui criant était en train d'enquêter sur
5000 cas de crimes de guerre qui se
seraient déroulées dans tout le pays moi
par rapport au débat qui a lieu ce soir
ce que je voulais ajouter c'est que en
effet il commence à y avoir des signes
que alors d'une part que le nombre de
crimes de guerre et extrêmement
impressionnant moi je me suis rendu en
reportage notamment pour radio france
internationale dans plusieurs localités
à bout de chat à boro janka hier mais
également à trottinette dans la région
de sony samedi dernier et moi ce qui me
frappe je ne suis pas un enquêteur en
tant que journaliste je suis là
également pour avoir des signaux faibles
mais ce qui me frappe c'est le début de
systématicité dans les modes opératoires
que le que l'on peut observer la
situation n'est pas la même dans toutes
les localités ce que j'ai vu à bord
janka hier qui est considérée comme la
ville la plus détruite de la région de
kiev n'a rien à voir avec la ville de
boudhha à bord dont deux cas la plupart
des victimes sont sans doute morts qu'en
raison de deux frappes aériennes
néanmoins on a également des témoignages
d'exactions de troupes russes qui vont
faire le tour des maisons pour sortir
les légendes et cours avec des questions
qui sont très précises c'est exactement
la même chose que j'ai retrouvé à cinq
heures de route de là à trausse tns dans
la région de soumis une petite ville de
20000 habitants où on voit que les
forces russes sont à la recherche de
profils particuliers on recherche des
personnes qui sont soit lié à l'armée
ukrainienne liées à la défense
territoriale
mais une des questions qui est posée
également très régulièrement c'est
est-ce que vous avez des liens avec la
mouvance de maidan donc en fait on voit
que les forces russes sont au delà de
cette guerre à la recherche de personnes
qui sont liées à ce qu'ils appellent au
sens large la mouvance nationaliste
ukrainienne et là on commence à avoir
des petits indicateurs des petits
signaux que en marge des combats il ya
quelque chose qui se passe que l'on
recherche un groupe particulier qu'en
tout cas il ya un groupe qui est
stigmatisé
bien entendu le travail de journaliste
et de reporter ce fait en instantané il
faudra encore ce travail d' enquête de
la part des enquêteurs internationaux et
ukrainiens mais on commence à voir des
choses qui en effet vos au delà des
crimes de guerre cécile coudriou donc ça
c'est on irait effectivement au delà des
crimes de guerre si d'après ce que dit
stéphane science si effectivement on
cible alors en particulier une
population celle qui a participé à
maidan donc était révolutionnaire pour 6
a franchi le cap je m'engage à programme
systématique et planifié effectivement
ça peut devenir des crimes contre
l'humanité comme on l'a vu en syrie par
exemple avec l'échelle à laquelle a été
pratiqué la torture ça devient des
crimes ou les disparitions forcées dont
parlait mon voisin tout à l'heure donc
ce qui effectivement tout à fait ce
rapport je rejoins tout à fait monsieur
c'est de dire qu'il y à des schémas
c'est à dire que le il ya vraiment des
schémas malheureusement qui ont été
d'ailleurs éprouvé d'abord à en syrie ou
en tchétchénie où on bombarde on
bombarde avec des armes indiscriminée
ensuite on assiège donc effectivement
les populations ne peuvent ni fuir ni
survivre avec le peu de nourriture et
même pas d'eau potable et encore moins
de soins donc on empêche les personnes
de partir alors qu'elle est plus
vulnérable en pur n'ont pas pu sortir
comme des personnes handicapées les
personnes très âgées ou les jeunes
enfants toi qui as vraiment cette
tactique de terreur qui a toujours été
pratiqué par admire poutine déjà
ailleurs et qui manifestement a été non
en tout cas documentés à kharkiv à
tchernihiv donc c'est vraiment dans
plusieurs régions dans plusieurs villes
mario paul n'en parlons pas évidemment
donc ça ce sont vraiment des choses qui
va falloir ensuite pouvoir comme on dit
tout à l'heure je me documente et me
remonter la chaîne de commandement et je
voudrais dire aussi qu'on n'a pas
beaucoup parlé alors qu'aujourd'hui a
quand même un événement c'est par
rapport au conseil des droits de l'homme
dont la russie s'aligne à la politique
je voulais parler aussi de du conseil de
sécurité parce que le problème quand
même c'est parce qu'il faut dire est
qu'elle a été aujourd'hui
suspendu des droits de l'homme de l'onu
symbolique et plus symboliquement
poliment la russie fait partie du chemin
depuis longtemps y compris depuis la
syrie c'est une réforme de ce droit de
veto au conseil de sécurité
et ça c'est quand même quelque chose qui
ne serait pas faire la guerre donc je
rejoins le général ne faut pas passer à
une escalade de troisième guerre
mondiale en tout cas seront parmi les
six qui va appeler à une intervention
armée en revanche ça fait longtemps que
nous disons que quelqu'un qui est partie
prenante d'un conflit kamla de telles
atrocités
il n'y a toujours pas de réforme pour
qu'il ne soit pas juge et partie et
qu'il ne puisse pas bloquer toute
résolution pour un cessez le feu pour un
convoi humanitaire pour un respect du
droit international humanitaire c'est
proprement hallucinant
donc là c'est toute la communauté
internationale qui doit renverser la
table littéralement est enfin arrivé
cette réforme
nicolas therrien joue fait réagir tous
justement sur cette peut-être possible
enfin réforme du conseil de sécurité est
hélas qui a on a parlé évidemment ce
droit de veto qui bloque mais
rappelé que les puissants dur ça a été
la plaine bien sûr c'était la position
de la france depuis d'ailleurs qu'il a
défendue il a défendu officiellement ans
parce qu'effectivement on a on a cinq
membres permanents donc la france les
états unis le royaume uni la chine et la
russie mais effectivement aujourd'hui on
peut penser que c'est une position qui
est bonne soutient entièrement mais qui
a malheureusement aujourd'hui quand même
peu de chances de voir le jour pour une
raison très simple c'est que précisément
on a le serpent qui se mord la queue en
quelque sorte c'est que on va avoir le
blocage de ces pays je voulais quand
même revenir une seconde sur la question
du crime délibéré il faut quand même
savoir qu' il y a eu des appels
parfaitement clair de vladimir poutine à
un nettoyage de la nation ukrainienne
des moutons dit quand on désigne des
adversaires comme des nazis dans le
prolongement de 1941 ça veut dire que ce
sont des ennemis absolus donc des
ennemis qu'il faut abattre
donc vous avez cette idéologie mortifère
une idéologie mortifère je voudrais y
assister aussi qui n'est pas nouvelle
c'est pour ça que je dis à la signature
de poutine c'est le crime c'est la
signature depuis ses années de dresde ou
kgb depuis ses années avec ses liens
avec le crime organisé quand il était
auprès de sobczak
saint pétersbourg et c'était la suite
aussi ça a été le lien à dire que
poutine est le crime d'une certaine
manière et le problème c'est que qu'on
n'a pas voulu voir avec ce qui se
passait à grossemy ce qui s'est passé
surtout en syrie on n'a pas voulu voir
ce que cela disait de la stratégie
internationale de monsieur poutine et
quand on a voulu faire un reset comme
obama en janvier 2009 au bac et une
architecture de sécurité de confiance
comme a voulu la france etc on n'a pas
vu la nature idéologique et la nature du
régime on a fait comme si c'était une
puissance normale comme si on pouvait
discuter comme si on pouvait négocier je
pense que ça a été la faune général
train qu'en sus assure cette leurs
efforts sur l'eau est venue d'abord la
réforme du conseil de sécurité
effectivement le droit de veto c'est un
projet qui est déporté la france depuis
longtemps simplement que le système de
réforme de l'onu est bloqué parce qu'il
faut que les cinq soit d'accord alors
forcément les autres ne sont pas
d'accord deuxième point en revanche je
voudrais attirer l'attention sur le vote
qui vient d'avoir du lieu sur les droits
de l'homme bravo ça a été remporté sauf
qu' à 57 abstentions
22 et 23 je crois vote contre ça veut
dire qu'en gros là partent la position
qui est de bannir la russie n'est pas
partagé par beaucoup de pays dans le
monde 80 et ça faudrait leur rappeler 93
qui envoie tes poils à 50 8 contre 58
contrat c'est pas glorieux quand même ça
laissait pas curieux 20 et donc si vous
voulez nous sommes sur une chaîne
internationale beaucoup de nos auditeurs
qui nous écoutent n'ont pas forcément la
même vision sur ce sujet là on a parlé
d' accidents isolés exactement mais
c'est ce qu'ils pensent j'interviens pas
mal sur des chaînes internationales et
parfois je suis bluffé des questions
qu'on pose je croyais que ça allait de
soi ben non ça va pas tuer vous savez
pourquoi sûr vous serez d'accord avec
moi c'est la question de l'exemplarité
moi je changeais dialogue beaucoup aussi
avec des personnes sur le continent
africain où d'autres qui me disent mais
c'est toujours les mêmes le souhaitais
qu'on va juger aussi george bush en 2003
comme ce fut le cas également échapper à
la justice et c'est ça qui est terrible
si on veut renforcer sa c'est aussi
vraiment le credo de restauration c'est
de renforcer les outils donc la cour
pénale internationale doit être crédible
parce qu'il sera totalement impartial et
donc effectivement il ya eu quand même
des premiers frémissements par exemple
pour l'afghanistan finalement entre en a
dit ah non ça sera que les talibans mais
pas les crimes commis par les états unis
ou le royaume uni ça ça ne va pas
emmanuel daoud vraiment que ce soit
impartial justement comment comment
sortir de ces de ces problématiques
sortir de ces pôles vient de révéler
c'est à dire ce deux poids deux mesures
mais c'est là c'est la réalité la cour
pénale internationale est qualifiée
parfois à raison comme étant comme
jugeant les plus faibles et uniquement
les plus faibles il ya qu'à voir les
dossiers qui ont abouti devant en phase
de jugement on a parlé de justice des
vainqueurs est exact que et s'agissant
d'ailleurs deux des premiers du tribunal
de nuremberg aussi on a parlé de justice
des vainqueurs dresde a été bombardé et
rasé cinq cent mille morts
hiroshima nagasaki
ça n'a pas été sanctionné on leur a fait
disparaître des villes donc il ya
toujours ce péché originel et on
n'arrive pas encore à le surmonter et on
arrivera à voir des pays qui croiront à
la réalité de l'exemplarité de cette
justice pénale internationale si les
responsables américains sont poursuivis
et sanctionnés dans la guerre sale en
afghanistan ou sur les bombardements des
populations civiles en irak et on peut
donner d'autres d'autres exemples je
voudrais juste attirer votre attention
mais juste pour cette année que sa durée
mais oui mais on va mais paré pour la
chine avec
les états unis n'ont pas reconnu la cpi
ni la russie ni la chine ni l'état
d'israël ni l'inde
non non non reconnu
le statut de rome mais il ya un point
que je joue sur lequel je voudrais
revenir simplement pour
oui je vous assure ça est extrêmement
rapide
l'idéologie mortifère que vous avez
souligné jeu simplement vous dire que
s'agissant de gènes du génocide tutsi
les patrons de la radio mille collines
qui sont restés là où il était à kigali
non pas qu'ils ont été sanctionnés pour
avoir véhiculé cette idéologie mortifère
au quotidien et en désignant les tutsi
comme étant des cafards donc et en
appelant au meurtre sur les ondes donc
ceux qui croient se retrancher derrière
le fait qu'il n'était pas sur le terrain
ils ne sont pas à l'abri de la justice
pénale n'a été condamné à d'accord mais
oui mais il faut tout ça prend du temps
et je termine juste un petit point là
dessus c'est que vous avez eu un
éditorial dans une agence fait
l'équivalent de la fp si vous voulez
russe à ria novosti
qui a parlé très clairement de solution
finale à propos de l'ukraine et c'est
exactement ça rentre dans ce que vous
définissez rien d'exhaustif avec la
solution soit celle de la justice et que
celle qu'on va appliquer à vladmir
poutine soit après la même qu'on
appliquera à d'autres et ainsi on ne
pourra plus remettre en cause des outils
dans le monde anglais joseph peut être
un temps très long et patient et très
rigoureux mais on y arrivera merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ses cils
coudriou merci à stéphane sirot ans qui
est avec nous en direct de kiev merci
avoue emmanuel daoud merci nicolas
tenzer merci général dominique traquant
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivis
vous restez avec nous sur france 24